welcome you all here to the the first of
a number of seminars of the Yale of Fox
International Fellowship is hosting on
the question of leadership and we're
looking at this from a variety
perspectives including environmental
leadership today's focus at the som in
December on the role of corporate social
responsibility and then at the Law
School in human rights and then went on
public health as well as having a
seminar a broader conference on the
topic in India that looks at the role
the emerging BRIC countries in
leadership my name is Ben Cara and I'm
the the Joseph C Fox director of the
Yale international Fox fellowship
program and I want to give you just a
couple of words about the program before
talking about our our two speakers who
both have written about leadership and
also on who are in fact practicing
leadership at the highest levels so
frozen who don't know the Yale Fox
International Fellowship is a exchange
program between Yale and 18 partner
universities around the world and what's
unique about this exchange program
unlike the Fulbright Program or the
rural scholarship is that it's a two-way
exchange so Yale sends to our partners
one or more exchange students who are
working the doctoral or master's level
on some kind of scholarship that also
has relevance for society and policy and
then likewise we bring into Yale and
many of you are here right now in this
audience from our partners to soak up
one year of academic scholarly and
cultural life at Yale and all of you who
are here from our partners also bring in
scholarship and a problem focused
approach to thinking about how to think
about solving and addressing some of the
most critical problems facing our planet
and all of you here in this room who are
Fox fellows and those who are now
partners are being chosen because of
their leadership promise in leaking
scholarship to practice and so those of
you who are in the room and are not Fox
fellows we certainly welcome you to
apply to the program
next year I look forward to talking you
about that the plan today is that we're
going to have a one-hour formal one hour
or we're going to have our two
presenters and talk for between 10 and
15 minutes then we're going to open it
up for question and answer from the
audience and then we'll have afterwards
starting at 6:00 a reception for those
you can stay and hang out and talk some
more informally so with that I first
want and I by the way let me just say I
cannot possibly do justice to introduce
our two speakers I'm going to give you a
gist of what they are about and what
they bring to this discussion so our
first speaker will be Julia Martin
lipophilic who is currently the Edward
bass distinguished Visiting
environmental scholar at Yale University
in our school right here for
experimental studies and who is the
former director of international union
for the conservation of nature but she
played critical roles in protecting some
of the world's most important in
critical biodiversity places she also is
I circled this the was former director
of the executive director of
International Council for science
those headquarters in Paris and is now
presently the chair of independent
advisory board to be sustainable biomass
partnership advising on those issues and
among many other accolades she was
elected as a member of the world academy
of art and science the World Future
Council and a fellow of the Royal
Geographic Society and who is now here
working so not only as she practices a
leader is also working on a book on
leadership so I'm gonna interest you
know Juliette Martin Lefevre and then
after is all introduced again after your
talk hello I'm very glad to meet all of
you I'd love to know who here is a Fox
fellow okay that's great and I know I've
looked it up you come from all over the
world many of the places that I've been
to so I look forward to speaking to you
before I really later on I really liked
her when I looked on the way
website about the goals of this
fellowship program by when it refers
specifically to enhancing mutual
understanding between peoples of the
United States and other countries I
trust that still in the mission and I
think this is extremely important and
we'll come back to that I think
understanding each other as it's so
obvious but and it's an obviously a
leadership and a survival tool but we're
not doing enough of it so that is great
that you're doing that and I'd love to
hear from you too of whether that's
working so I just want to suggest a
slight revision to the title of this
dialogue to replace the word environment
with sustainability I know Dan you're
probably in agreement with that I think
we're now on fully on a journey towards
sustainable development environment is
one part of it and and so equally
important are the economic and the
social parts so I don't know if one can
do that so I've had this really
privileged professional personal and
professional journey living in diverse
continents and for many years leading
some of the most important international
science and and environmental
organizations and the question of what
leadership skills are needed in our
world was probably the one that was most
often repeated throughout these
different experiences and there is no
doubt that we're very poor and giving
you a good answer
I don't know if any of you know that
just a few hours ago we got the United
Nations is very close to formally
electing a man named Antonio Guterres
from Portugal to be the next Secretary
General of the UN and he's an extremely
good person however many people were
looking for a woman leader after all
these so um and that's an interesting
interesting thing what happened there
but some of you women who are sitting
here or young enough to think five or
ten years ahead think about it but get
yourselves organized early one of the
leadership skills I think that's needed
is organization so towards the end of
the 19th as a part of my my journey now
toward the end of the 1990s I was sought
out by the Rockefeller Foundation to
head up a very interesting program
called leadership for environment and
development programs the lead program
and I accepted this job mostly
cause in my previous job as the head of
the International Council for science
which is this very old respected
professional non-governmental
organization with a membership in all
the countries academies of Sciences
international scientific unions and I
had this great job to be the director
there but one of the frustrations always
was that when we were sitting in our
beautiful meeting room thinking about
putting together a new committee on
climate change on biotechnology on
biodiversity we almost always came up
with the same people really great people
many of them have received the Nobel
Prize this week or before and but they
were mostly men they were mostly on the
other side of 60 and mostly came from
the so-called developed world I don't
like those divisions anymore but anyway
they came from the United States from
Europe from Canada so lead and and we
realized that we just didn't know the
other people there was there is talent
in the world out there you you represent
that but we just didn't know this
distinguished organization just didn't
know so I accepted the chance to lead
this lead program which really and I'm
gonna talk to you a little bit because
it was about leadership but lead really
set out first of all to look for that
talent it started out as a headhunting
organization you really need to find
people who show leadership skills I
think that's part of how you were found
and we looked for talented mid-career
people and from different walks of life
from academia from business from NGOs
from the government and from media and
normally these people don't naturally
meet and and get to know each other so
building bridges between disciplines and
cultures was at the heart of this lead
program and it was really this has was
always and has certainly become a very
important part of my professional life I
think I'm gonna call my book something
to do with building bridges so so the
lead approach to training I wanted to
talk to you about that training leaders
and sustainable development issues and
enhancing leadership skills use
cross-sectoral and cross-cultural
experience all methods which are which
have been
to transform the lives of these
individuals when I was much younger and
I spent some time in this country my
parents were political refugees you hear
a lot of those people now - I learned
English I did a lot of great things and
I joined the Peace Corps I don't know if
any of you know what that is but that
was a life-changing experience for me I
probably wouldn't be here if I didn't
have that so I was very much interested
in providing life-changing experiences
for these thousands of lead fellows who
we were training from many of your
countries and I presume that that was
also in the mind of the Fox fellowship
so leads so leads premise was that
living within our within our economic
and ecological means demands
far-reaching policy institutional and
technological reforms complemented by
shifts in individual values and behavior
and that's what sustainable development
is about it's about changing the way we
think and the way we live and that
requires a new kind of leadership and
you all have the responsibility to
either take those positions or find
those people in your countries so lead
goal was to empower emerging leaders to
manage the necessary changes towards
more sustainable patterns of development
obviously a major challenge facing
decision-makers in all countries in the
creation of policies that reflects the
link between economic prosperity and
healthy environment and social equity is
that's the biggest problem and it's very
difficult to do that in the present way
that systems are set up in different
government departments different UN
agencies and bodies and perhaps even
different university departments so it's
extremely important to try to build
those bridges even the explanation of
what sustainable development is is
probably not understood by most people
on the streets I like to use one that
was invented by a very distinguished
English gentleman British gentleman who
did a lot in this field he called it
getting getting people to treat their
passage on this earth
as if they intended to stay so treating
the earth as if you intended to stay if
you intended to stay you'd want to make
sure it's gonna be good for you maybe
it's a little bit more a little bit too
abstract to think about future
generations and especially if some of
you still don't have you're too young to
have children maybe so because of this
intrinsically inter interdisciplinary
nature of sustainable development it's
really not easy to build leadership
capacities in settings where disciplines
are divided by these six thick walls and
this is still the model in many
countries and I hope that you're gonna
go home and change that we're trying our
best in in universities and I'm working
very much on a reform in the
international system to so lead lead
provided a non-academic training there
is nothing wrong with academic training
obviously and that's why I'm here but
this particular training was non
academic focused on four interrelated
themes and skills developing a set of
shared shared is the word here ethics
and values consistent with the
objectives of sustainable development
building knowledge you need to have
knowledge of key sustainable development
challenges and their potential solutions
we can no longer just talk about
problems and and and all of this had to
be done both at local and global levels
then we talked about strengthening key
leadership skills and I'll come back to
that and supporting collaboration and
peer learning amongst this diverse
multinational network of professionals
so again building big bridges so for
sustainable development to start to work
everyone has to play a role and a and a
change must occur at the level of every
individual that's going to be your tasks
when you go home to your countries so
our approach was to offer a very
hands-on experience involving action
oriented projects case studies joint
problem-solving activities discussions
with stakeholders and the sharing of new
knowledge among peers so even though I
was a director believe me I learned as
much as the the the lead fellows as we
call them so
I felt and I hired some really big
thinkers about leadership training that
experiential learning is the best way
for adult learners to develop skills and
knowledge to bring about a positive
change so lead training was was designed
to build a confidence and understanding
to allow participants to put their
skills and knowledge into action
immediately was was not an academic
training it was a good complement to
academic training so here were the
critical leadership skills that we
developed over the years and these are
still very important I think in
leadership thinking about how to build
leadership so first of all self
awareness and understanding understand
your values who you are where you come
from system thinking very important for
transformational change helping people
to think systemically about their goals
understanding the dynamics that are
involved and the possible resistance
that they might face and the timeframe
needed to achieve their goals that's all
system thinking it's extremely important
then helping people to communicate
effectively in diverse and multicultural
environments I have to say that at times
when I speak with people at Yale who
come from a totally different discipline
I at least have now have the courage to
say I'm so sorry but I really didn't
understand about a half of what you're
saying because you're using jargon
acronyms technical technical terms
don't ever be embarrassed to say that
you know your intelligence I no one's
gonna think you're stupid and if the
other person thinks that that's their
problem so I always ask I think I've
asked a couple of you a couple of times
too and I think that I think that's this
communication is very important but you
need to understand each other to
communicate then this multicultural
approach to all aspects of sustainable
development it is not an issue that is
only a part of your culture or this
culture it's it affects all of us and so
this multi-sectoral and multicultural
approach we arrange that and I think
you're doing the same thing by
people from different countries together
and from different disciplines and it
wasn't easy at first everybody sort of
looked at each other suspiciously but at
the end and then using collaborative
approaches for solving problems and
finally we also well and then we
explored leadership through discussions
and practice by facilitating dialogue
among the different voices everyone had
had a role here and helping groups value
the diversity and the richness in the
conversations and including a diversity
in the way you express yourself language
is what we have and and then of course
we also address the ethical basis and
background to decision-making it's it's
not enough to talk about corruption
let's understand where it comes from
visioning was a tool to develop share
meaning and I think probably the most
important thing which I trust as a part
of the Fox program is that we were
really creating and motivating a highly
effective highly effective teams for
networking so that the experience of the
lead fellows actually was was but was
more important after the training they
knew each other and they trusted each
other and takes a while as you know I'll
never forget when a former dean of the
of the of the forestry and environmental
school at Yale had this is just Beth was
at one point the head of the United
Nations Development Program when I was a
head of the lead program and he said to
me at one point he said I can see that
there were a lot of lead fellows at this
UN meeting that he was in charge of
because the the normally a UN meeting
people don't talk to each other very
much they read their speeches and leave
don't listen to the other person but
certainly they don't really get up to go
talk to another delegation from a
totally different continent he said you
could see that it was quite messy people
were going giving hugs to each other and
actually starting to speak in a similar
language so it's very very I think
that's very important there's networking
which of course has to be based by trust
so this on trust so this lead training
was very participate
participatory and had this strong peer
learning component and the method
methods included case studies unselected
sustainability themes that everybody
looked at site visits problem-solving
activities simulation and roleplay there
that's a great way to learn what the
other might think it's difficult but
it's it's important interactive
presentations and panel discussions
distance learning and individual and
group projects so again as I say
although I was the director of this
amazing program I thought that I learned
so much from the lead fellows and we
have formed this incredible team of
people around the world who help each
other and who are well placed and I
think now the next thing to do is that
these different networks of leadership
programs should should connect we should
connect the dots between you because
that will strengthen no no not one
person can solve the challenges that we
face in our world today so you're just
going to be a part of a larger group
this is not this leadership is can no
longer be about a personal ego trip it
has to be the the servant leader who is
a part of a community and we need to be
together on this journey toward
sustainability so I look forward to your
questions that was really interesting
and helpful and I just wanted to
emphasize that in fact the Yale of Fox
Fellowship is a networking organization
and in fact we have a saying in the
fellowship that once a Fox fellow you
are always a fox fellow we now have
almost 700 alumni around the world who
are now in leadership positions who are
now being part of this process and in
fact we're having a international
reunion in India in January to foster
that kind of network so I'm taking your
advice
so I'd love to connect that group with
at least 400 Indian lead fellows thank
you
and also I think the other thing that
was really important was the one about
this is a collective endeavor it's not
an ego driven endeavor so thank you very
much I'm turning to our next guest a
speaker the
a challenge I have is that it's not
possible to do justice to dynasties
career as a leader both as a
practitioner and as a scholar just a few
highlights that you can go back to the
1992 a real Earth Summit the first one
and he was a high-level official working
for the Bush administration at that time
when he was 10 or something though a
little bit older but not much and since
that time has done really wonderful
things at Yale including being the
founding director of the Yale rural
Fellows Program that brings in leaders
from the practitioner world in their mid
30s and 40s and also was a founder of
the Center for business in the
environment at Yale which is now a
thriving
I think decade old now program leaking
leaders around business sustainability
and most recently aside from being the
hill host professor at the Yale
Environment and law schools of an
appointment also in the business Google
imagine was cool he was the Commissioner
of energy in the environment in
Connecticut for three years in which he
led a number of initiatives to get a
Connecticut on its little carbon pathway
so and let me just finally say that he's
written a wonderful article and the
public administration review on his
experience are that but points to it
with the kinds of leadership skills you
would want to think about so we're happy
to send you that article just let us
know we're happy to do that what can you
post on the web the website as well so
with that Dan I'll both of them thank
you thank you Ben it's a great pleasure
to be as Julia who I have known for many
many years and we you will see wander
back and forth across some similar
themes but that's always a good strategy
in fact I would urge you to take that on
board as part of your leadership
thinking and that is to triangulate on
difficult problems and if two people
tell you the same place that the best
path forward might lie that's better
than one person telling you and if three
tell you the same thing it really can
start to be a sign of where to look I
want to pick up on what Ben said
thirty years ago I was joining the
federal government in Washington as a
young official at the EPA and 28 years
ago began negotiating on climate change
and I want to use that as a theme for my
conversation today because today is a
very big day for climate change I don't
know if any of you were following this
issue but in the spirit of our
sustainability focus yesterday the
European Union's Parliament ratified the
new climate change agreement that was
worked out in Paris last December and
that ratification means as soon as it's
certified at the UN as early as today if
not tomorrow that the agreement worked
out last December goes into effect
because it required 55 ratifying parties
and we're now over 60 but it also
required 55% of green of greenhouse gas
emissions parties to sign up and the
European Union puts us over that total
so it's a very big day and I am excited
because I've spent the majority of my
life working on this problem and I want
to tell you that 1992 which you heard
was when we launched this Framework
Convention on Climate Change was a very
exciting time for me I was a young
official we got not only this treaty
done but we also had this Rio Earth
Summit which launched the concept of
sustainable development in many regards
we also had a biodiversity treaty signed
and a desert a'f ocation treaty and i
thought as a young official wow it is so
great to be able to get people together
five rounds of negotiations and we had a
climate treaty pull people together from
ago she ations we have a desert
application treaty and I thought well
you know this is all gone so well it
pretty much solved the climate change
problem I guess I can leave Washington
and come to Yale of course that didn't
quite work out as I had thought and we
are still today facing both the
excitement of a new treaty coming into a
new agreement coming into force but also
today we have a very powerful hurricane
pounding the Caribbean
hit Haiti yesterday Cuba earlier today
is now pounding the Bahamas very force
powerful force for hurricane and that's
a reminder that we haven't done all that
we need to do and it's also a reminder I
think that we need to understand
something very important about
leadership and I want to take you back
to that Rio Earth Summit of 1992 again
I'm 31 years old
and the leader of the Earth Summit comes
to visit the US EPA Environmental
Protection Agency and takes me aside
while we're waiting to meet with my boss
and says and this is Morris strong who
was the secretary-general of that Earth
Summit very important Canadian
businessman diplomat twice Secretary
General's of these global gatherings of
world leaders and he said Dan I want to
remind you of one thing as we closed in
on our Rio Earth Summit in a few months
when we bring together all those
presidents and prime ministers all of
their cabinets and staffs and the press
and and all of the NGOs that will be
there as well only two outcomes are
possible success and real success and I
am sad to report that at Rio we thought
we had success we launched a treaty we
launched these other things but for most
of the last intervening 24 years we did
not have real progress on addressing
climate change so I want to say with
this theme of real success because I
think leadership goes beyond political
leadership or symbolic leadership to
substance and I would urge all of you
you are here because you have the
capacity to play on the substance
analytic rigor tenacious commitment to
real change in people's lives and to
taking on the hard problems not the easy
ones or I think some of the hallmarks of
leadership so that is an absolutely
critical starting point second I think
you have to think big because if you
think small
you will go smaller if you think big you
may fail but you will be aiming high and
you need to start big in order to get
anywhere I think it's also important to
go fast when opportunities present
themselves and that is often hard if
you're doing things in an international
setting because there's a lot of parties
to bring together but run with the
opportunities and with that I want to
also say where you are going to make
progress and how you are going to make
progress may often turn out to be not
where you thought not where you thought
in terms of position not where you
thought in terms of the substance of the
action you're trying to take and just
one example in that regard you heard
from Ben that I've just come off three
years on leave from Yale running
Connecticut's the state of Connecticut's
Department of Energy and Environmental
Protection and I never imagined as a
young official that I would run a
state-level Environment Agency but when
I was presented the opportunity and I
had a parallel possibility of going to
Washington I realized that in Washington
our government of the United States has
badly broken down and that it made more
sense to go with a governor in a state
who was excited about my agenda which
included by the way creating a
Department of Energy and Environmental
Protection combined which is one of my
core themes I think another element
leadership is and you heard it from
Julia and another way of saying it
systemic thinking thinking in an
integrated way not in a narrow way not
in a silo but understanding the
dimensions of a problem in a in their
full complexity and I believe that
environmental progress sustainability
progress as julia has quite rightly said
we should focus on depends on
integrating energy and environment and
for that matter economic thinking as
well so I went off to Connecticut and
had a governor who was excited about
this created a new department and did a
number of things that I could never have
done in Washington because of the
political breakdown notably creating a
Green Bank and that was a chance to use
limited government
money to leverage private capital the
old model of how you do clean energy as
the government picks some projects and
subsidizes them but that allows you to
do very small number of projects because
it takes a very large amount of support
if you use the limited money to attract
private capital we found in Connecticut
you could do ten times as many projects
so thinking fresh looking for
opportunities that you didn't expect
very very important the other thing I
want to tell you is that this is all not
going to be easy and when people ask me
what did you learn as commissioner of
Connecticut's Department of Energy and
Environmental Protection leading an
organization of eighteen hundred people
and trying to make a difference on these
complicated topics and here's what I
tell them change is hard even when the
status quo what's going on now is
plainly not working even when it's just
obvious that it's failing people still
cling to what they know so any and all
of you I think are going to be called
upon to deliver change and I would tell
you it's gonna turn out to be much
harder than you think
even when it seems plainly obvious that
some kind of change and transformation
is required but I would also tell you
that that is again a critical element of
leadership leadership depends on being
willing to go out there and deliver on a
change agenda even when nobody else
wants it and that is requires some
dimension of other elements several of
which Julia is highlighted now I want to
highlight a few others number one in my
mind is vision you have to know where
you're gonna try to go and you have to
be willing to articulate it and convince
people that where you want to go is
worth they're gumming with you second
and related to this idea that you've got
to transform I think you have to be
prepared to innovate I have come to
believe that innovation is a critical
leadership value because almost always
with true leaders
have to look at the scene and then
figure out how to turn it take it in a
new direction and bring core
constituencies critical stakeholders
along with them and so let me just step
back again to climate change why did we
make so little progress on this critical
issue of reducing greenhouse gas
emissions from the signing of a treaty
in 1992 to last December what went wrong
I think that people like me put together
a failed model of how to deliver change
we had the idea and this was the spirit
of the times by the way I don't hold
myself too personally responsible I was
one of hundreds negotiating and I was
very junior so I'm only a little bit
responsible but I consider it tragic
that we had this sort of step in the
wrong direction so here's what we got
wrong we thought a strategy of
high-level targets and timetables said
at the national level with presidents
and prime ministers behind them would
get us where we needed to go and it
turns out the problem of climate change
is almost not at all controlled by
presidents and prime ministers they have
very little to say over the carbon
footprints of their societies what was
required to required was not a top-down
strategy but much more of a bottom-up
strategy pulling into the conversation
and into the action the people that
really do have control over greenhouse
gas emissions who turn out to be mayors
and city scale actions governor's or
premiers and stare provincial scale or
regional scale leaders CEOs and
corporate leaders who make the decisions
of what products we buy and how they're
made and community leaders who are
engaging the public and helping to move
them towards changed behavior so we had
the wrong strategy of how to change
behavior it was not gonna happen
top-down had to happen bottom-up we
needed a much broader engagement to get
people to really change the behavior and
shift towards a sustainable energy
future second terrible terrible mistake
we agreed in that original agreement
consolidated at the
five years later at the Kyoto Protocol
on a approach to who should take action
that turned out to be mistaken we ended
up with a set of countries forty
countries the most developed countries
who are obligated to step up and take
action they were called the annex 1
countries and everybody else was invited
to take action but not required and
almost everybody else sat on the
sidelines for 20 years
and it turned out to be a huge mistake
because we couldn't get the 40 countries
that were in the front of the action to
really go forward without everybody else
and the emissions of the everybody else
were shooting up while the 40 were
actually pretty level rising just
slightly so we missed the big part of
the problem and it turned out that a
couple of critical countries number one
the United States decided that they
didn't want to act if the developing
countries weren't gonna act and the
United States Senate actually passed a
resolution to that effect that said
don't bring us any more action on
climate change until the developing
world is coming with us and that
resolution called the bird hegel
resolution set the tone of American
politics for 15 years only overcome in
the last year so the second big thing
done in Paris was we got rid of this NX
1 vs. non annex 1 countries distinction
and all countries are now engaged
everybody is on the playing field nobody
is sitting on the sidelines and each
country and a hundred and eighty-eight
of them have actually taken this up was
invited to produce a nationally
determined contributions to addressing
the problem prior to the Paris agreement
they were called intended nationally
determined contributions you see an
acronym IND C now it's an in DC but each
country is telling you what they're
gonna do to move the problem forward and
I think having everyone in the game
hugely important and again an element of
revision it seemed unimaginable five
years ago but critical to re-energizing
the process third in the prior time of a
20th century I was involved in many many
environmental conversations including
the climate change negotiations and we
almost never ask the question where is
the money gonna come from to do all the
good things we need to do we made what I
like to call the lawyers mistake and I
can say that as a lawyer we thought if
you passed the law wrote the regulations
negotiated the treaty the job was done
that's why I came to Yale I thought the
job was done I thought we've ordered
everybody to address climate change it's
gonna happen and it didn't happen
because no one thought about
implementation so again a critical
element of leadership is not just
setting the vision its execution or
implementation and to forget that is to
forget the critical issues and by the
way no one in business ever forgets this
no one in business that you know if you
told them you got the treaty done they
would say well that's like writing the
business plan what's the action plan how
do you implement that and so we made a
terrible lawyers mistake and I think
only now 20 plus years later are we
correcting it and the spirit of that
conversation in Paris last December and
I think all of us were there was about
solutions and action and who is going to
do what on the ground to change behavior
and so I think again vision and
execution are the two sides of critical
leadership and there are a number of
other elements you can't get people to
come with you if you haven't listened to
them so engagement both in your
organization and externally well whoever
the critical stakeholders of your
enterprise might be you've got to have
shared ownership ultimately of the
direction you're trying to go Julia said
it been repeated it this is not a solo
game leadership it's a team sport and
unless you pull lots of people with you
you're not going to get where you need
to go second the prospect of getting it
all right in the first pass almost zero
so a spirit of continuous improvement is
a critical skill for a leader and a
willingness as I just did to say you
were wrong which is not being modeled
very well in our presidential campaign
here in the United States so I would
urge you not to watch that as a model of
leadership but it's important to say
when you didn't get it right because
otherwise people just keep going down
the wrong track and it's better to stop
step back and redeploy effort and energy
and limited resources in a new strategy
if something has hit a at a wall and I I
do also want to say that persistence is
critical because it may well be some of
these problems are hard enough that it
will take 23 years to get on the right
track
Gus Beth who was a great Dean here and a
great environmental leader we invited
back to Yale a few years ago to give a
medal of lifetime service to the
environment and he was so depressed in
the speech he gave we almost had to
invite suicide counselors in yeah
were you there I mean it was a really a
tragedy because he felt everything had
collapsed I would say you can't think of
it that way it's got to be that you're
in a long-term change mode persistence
is what matters and that you didn't get
everywhere you wanted to go in the first
period or the second or even the third
is the hard challenge of really big
leadership issues so the bottom line
again always aim for real success thank
you very much